tonight fox news has learned the federal
probe into president biden's son hunter
being conducted by the u.s attorney in
delaware has reached a quote critical
stage the tax probe has been going on
for years but we're told the
investigation expanded in recent months
hunter biden could face a number of
specific charges if prosecutors decide
to move forward correspondent david
spunt has been following this story has
the breaking news tonight
at the top of the show good evening
david good evening brett the clock is
ticking tonight fox news can confirm
things are moving toward a head in the
federal investigation into hunter biden
a source familiar with the investigation
confirms the grand jury tasked with
looking at potential evidence has
wrapped up its latest term in this case
in recent weeks the case may now be in
the hands of the government the
department of justice to make the next
move the president's son has not been
charged with a crime but is under
investigation and has been since 2018
for tax issues and overseas business
dealings the source said the u.s
attorney and justice department
officials were looking into whether to
charge hunter with various tax
violations and more seriously possible
foreign lobbying violations and possible
false statements when joe biden became
president biden he kept on a man named
david weiss the u.s attorney in delaware
a trump appointee sources say president
biden did so to avoid an appearance of a
conflict of interest brett attorney
general merrick garland has been asked
about the hunter binded investigation
for over a year now multiple times every
time he says he's staying clear letting
u.s attorney weiss in delaware conduct
the investigation we'll continue to
follow we will follow that meantime
david the government rested its case in
the steve bannon trial today that's
correct another big one we're watching
he's on trial for attempt after refusing
a subpoena by the house committee
investigating the attack on the capitol
january 6 2021. today the chief counsel
for that panel suggested bannon may have
had advance knowledge of that incident
meanwhile the january 6 committee
council who was appearing as a witness
today her name is kristin amerling she
confirmed she's in a book club with one
of the prosecutors on the government's
team the two met some 15 years ago brett
bannon's case will brannan's team will
present its case to the jury tomorrow
morning though it's still not clear if
he will specifically testify
we'll follow it david thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else